[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
mélenchon l'okapi szijjarto portable ou
de noces
veux tu me laisser dire bonsoir à nos
petits amis le nounours notre ami
nounours a tellement envie de danser
qu'il est intenable bon descend vite
chez nicolas et pimprenelle nous montrer
comment tu dans cette capucine aux rues
toujours genou gauche molle europe au
pommeau bon bon bon bon bon bon bon bon
et voilà des capucines des capucines
partout ses portes à seynod alors donjon
une vive le cas du sud
[Musique]
dans salt a fait signer n'y a pas de
passé nous niono c'est la voisine mais
ce n'est pas pour nous dansons la
capucine onia de la joie chez nous on
perd chez la voisine
cochez do you you
aidez moi à me relever les petits je ne
peux plus je sais rien
ça lui est holla holla aux deux mois oh
oh oh ça va mieux
bon ça fait du bien de rire pas présent
je suis sérieux ballon au lit
[Musique]
[Rires]
quel rôle y aura bonne nuit les enfants
jacky muneaux on s'amuse bien avec toi
t'y c'est bon si je m'amuse bien avec
vous mes petits galerie du roi j'éteins
la lumière faites de beaux rêves
aurez vous aussi des enfants
après cette jolie ronde allez vite vous
coucher comme nicolas et pimprenelle ce
qu'on avril patron
heureusement mon nounours ben et nuit
bono
[Musique]
non
oh
en
[Applaudissements]